meinen heutigen gast meine damen und
herren kennen sie ganz bestimmt
er gab neben sean connery den bösewicht
lago im james-bond-film farinas nie und
spielte den ungeliebten ehemann von
meryl streep in jenseits von afrika auf
der bühne varel hamlets king lear und
viele figuren mehr
seit vielen jahren ist er mitglied des
berühmten wiener burgtheaters und dafür
doch erfolgreich regie klaus maria
brandauer vielleicht fragen sie sich
genauso wie ich wie schafft man es
eigentlich in so unterschiedlichen
rollen zu schützen gibt es hinter den
vielen figuren einen echten klaus maria
brandauer und was genau heißt es
überhaupt echt zu sein
ich freue mich auf jeden fall sehr klaus
maria brandauer in echt hier begrüßen zu
dürfen herzlich willkommen herr
brandauer sie sind zurzeit artist in
residence des zürcher kammerorchesters
geben diesen dienstag ein erstes konzert
mit dem orchester der titel des
konzertes ist krieg es lebe der krieg
ausrufezeichen fragezeichen provokanter
titel was bedeutet er im grunde steht im
mittelpunkt das stück das konzert die
geschichte vom soldaten von igor
strawinsky musikalisch erarbeitet und
von ramiz die texte das ist die
geschichte eines jungen soldaten
der 14 tage urlaub hat und der sich
wahnsinnig freut nach auszukommen zu
seiner frau so sei den kindern zu seiner
mutter aber unterwegs begegnete er
jemanden der eben einiges verspricht
und trotzdem könnte er nach haus aber er
kann unterwegs ein bisschen sein leben
besser gestalten mit dem was dieser kerl
ihm verspricht aber er muss ihn dafür
seine geige geben die ihr vor vielen
jahren für zehn franken gekauft hat und
das ist sein liebstes stück das das
mitunter gar ist wie ein mensch für ihn
aber schließlich gibt diese geige her
das ist die geschichte es ist schon
blitzen in ihren augen und und da man
dieses werk vielleicht nicht ganz allein
ein aufhören sollte haben wir uns für
vielen jahren einen ein vorspiel
komponieren lassen das ist allerdings
schon gab nämlich ludwig von beethoven
das vorspiel zu egmont also sozusagen
diese riesige symphonie die von kraft
und vom sieg spricht aber jan müller
wieland freund von uns hat uns das so
hingestellt ohne den beethoven zu
beschädigen dass am ende dieser
sogenannten ouvertüre zum egmont
eigentlich alles irgendwie
auseinanderfällt herunterfällt und zu
bricht und da gibt es einen satz und der
heißt wir wollen in die schlacht gehen
wie ich euch jetzt meine herrschaften
und allen anderen die im volk dafür sind
dass dieser krieg stattfindet wie ich
euch ein beispiel ich euch ein beispiel
geben
das heißt dieser fällt der region er
fährt in einem moment wo zu mache ich
das überhaupt lohnt sich das überhaupt
hat es einen sehen darf es krieg
überhaupt geben das ist die geschichte
und dazu gibt es noch texte von kafka
vorher das heißt damit wir die wir in
der tonhalle sitzen am nächsten dienstag
nämlich auch wir die wir auf der bühne
sind und im zuschauerraum ein bisschen
eingestimmt werden weil krieg ist etwas
was immer trotz allen fernsehberichten
jeden abend ganz weit weg von uns
scheint jetzt zwar ja nicht immer so was
bedeutet für sie denn krieg ganz
persönlich menschen bringen sich um für
eine idee für fürs land warum weiß ich
eigentlich auch nicht als kind konnte
mir vorstellen dass man krach bekommen
und auch das erwachsene kraft bekommen
aber wie das dann schließlich aussieht
und was das eigentlich bedeutet dass das
versteht man erst nach und nach das
kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen auf
die erziehung an
man ist natürlich in einem haus sind wo
sagt also die schweiz ist die schweiz
und alles was die schweiz anbelangt und
wer das nicht möchte oder an greift das
müssen wir verteidigen so dass jedes
land oder jeder landstrich sich einfach
herausnimmt und so sagt sobald einer
nicht so tun wie wir das abend wollen
gibt es krieg
und das wissen wir einfach im grund
genommen fühle ich mich nie wohl bei
diesem thema weil ich eigentlich fast
weinen möchte ich kenne die geschichte
ich habe da immer gut aufgepasst seit
jahrtausenden und es kracht
ununterbrochen würden sie denn so weit
gehen zu sagen wie das vielleicht ernst
jünger beschrieben hat krieg ist doch so
etwas wie eine naturgewalt ernst jünger
mit seinem buch die stahlgewitter wo man
den eindruck hat es wird beschrieben
eben wie ein gewitter
das bricht einfach über die menschheit
hinein da kann eigentlich auch gar nicht
viel dagegen drei literarisch kann man
das ja gut beschreiben und das hat auch
der jünger gut beschrieben der war ja
selbst im krieg oder wenn wir im westen
nichts neues von erich maria remarque
nehmen also wir kennen viel literatur
aus dem krieg und egal wie der schreiber
es irgendwie gemeint hat man kann
darüber nicht glücklich sein dass es
sowas gibt also ich weiß es schon dass
es auch einen romantischen bezug zum
krieg und dass man das gefühl hat man
muss familie verteidigen und gut
verteidigen oder die menschen
verteidigen deren am herzen liegt das
kann schon alles sein ich bin weit davon
entfernt ein pazifist zu sein aber ich
möchte doch unterbrochen
immer wieder fragen nämlich den satz
benützen von bertolt brecht stellt euch
vor um 4 ist krieg aber keiner geht hin
so einfach ist ist und noch einmal ich
fühle mich unwohl bei dem thema weil man
ist natürlich denn sie seien kein
pazifist ich bin kein pazifist weil ich
mir vorstellen kann dass es um ständig
gibt in denen man plötzlich denkt da
müssen wir uns also stehen sie immer vor
es um ein haus herum kommen leute von
denen ich weiß sie wollen ununterbrochen
das haus erobern und meine familie töten
da werde ich mir überlegen ob ich
pazifist bin oder nicht und das will ich
mir noch auf behalten für so einen
moment also ich schließe überhaupt
nichts aus ich meint meine überlegungen
sind auch noch nicht abgeschlossen ich
möchte nur dass man nicht am abend im
fernsehen bilder sieht vom krieg die
übrigens auch sehr leicht schon weg
gehalten werden von
wenn früher irgendwas vom krieg waren
wann das auch schon von uns weg halten
wollte kam plötzlich eine eine eines
evtl
da war die escon valdez ein öltanker
irgendwo vor der küste amerikas also
leck geworden und da war eine sehr möge
die also kurzform vor and nist und die
flattert noch so und und versucht noch
irgendwie da herauszukommen und dann
haben die leute offensichtlich begriffen
dass so das aber das sind ja mensch
nicht dass einem keine wert hat und
diese bilder zu sehen und jetzt bilder
und seien sie auch nur kurz aus aleppo
und die gespräche und die schicken
anzüge der oder die darüber reden
da hat man manchmal das gefühl auf
welcher welt in welcher zeit lebe ich
überhaupt sie sprechen diese bilder an
ich habe bilder ausgesucht als holmes
die sind das ganze jahr über immer
wieder im internet kursiert diese
stammen hier vom februar diesen jahres
sie haben schon erwähnt im moment vor
allem bilder aus mossul aber auch aus
aleppo ähnliche bilder grauenhafte
bilder man kann es nicht anders sagen
wie genau denken sie denn sollte und
kann die kunst spezifisch darauf
reagieren also erst einmal sind dass
bilder natürlich ist das nicht berlin
aber es hätte berlin sein können und
solche bilder wollten wir alle nicht
mehr sehen nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
und alles wurde getan von vielen
interessanten und wissenden leuten von
wirklich toll menschen um zum beispiel
zunächst einmal dieses europa zu
befrieden eine fantastische idee der
gründerväter der europäischen union
es hat lange gedauert es war sehr sehr
schwierig ist weil besonders schwierig
todfeinde wie die franzosen und die
deutschen und so weiter und die russen
irgendwie an einen tisch zu bekommen
zunächst einmal ging es halt mit der
westlichen seite irgendwie voran
und da hat man gehofft und gehofft und
gehofft und 1989 irgendwie schneit es
auch noch herein eine vereinigung der
beiden deutschland und eine ein
zusammenschluss eigentlich ein frei
werden durch gorbatschows politik
der länder von den sowjets unterjochten
ländern im osten ein aufschrei und es
war für mich persönlich übertrieben
gesprochen
der dreißigjährige krieg endlich zu ende
weil bis dato 89 war ununterbrochen
europa dirigent ein scharmützel oder ein
schwerer kriegt also die hoffnung ich
lebe in frieden und in der hoffnung
jetzt könnte es doch einmal klappen und
sie können sich vorstellen wie ich mir
immer zu mutig bin wenn ich denke was
eigentlich für schwierigkeiten wir mit
der europäischen union mit dem
zusammenwachsen dieser länder jedoch nur
profitiert haben ja was ist passiert was
und da wird vielleicht der jünger dann
schon recht haben das was heißt der
krieg kommt ihre uns aber irgendjemand
muss ihnen doch betreiben oder sind wir
normalen bürger zu blöd oder haben gar
keine macht oder haben uns nur von der
demokratie so berieseln lassen damit wir
sand in die augen gestreut bekommen und
machen dann am schluss doch mit indem
wir uns erklären lassen das ist dieses
mal notwendig wer kann mir erklären dass
die ukraine krise notwendig ist
ich lasse noch mit mir darüber reden
dass es vielleicht landstrich oder
begradigungen an grenzen wird darüber
dass ich mit mir noch reden nur dass
diese kriege stattfinden oder immer
wieder die jetzt noch sind scharmützeln
aber dass wir unter eigentlich dem
schwert dem tanken will schweer eines
größeren krieges durchaus sind darüber
die welt geht weiter also und wenn der
jünger recht hat dann dann bin ich erst
recht verzweifelt ich werde mich morgen
nicht ermorden einer familie nicht aber
mir geht es da nicht gut und ich würde
mich gern fast zurück ins persönliche
sehr betroffen lassen sie mich noch
einmal auf die frage zurückkommen was
genau kann die musik spezifische oder
das theater spezifisch zu dieser
situation beitragen oder zur klärung
dieser situation wo sehen sie die rolle
der holly ist ganz einfach dass wir
darüber reden ich habe mir noch nie
eingebildet dass ich durch theater durch
die artis stücke die welt verändern kann
leider leider leider habe ich das
gedacht was jung war sicherlich als
junger bursch habe ich gedacht werden
welt verbessern deshalb bin ich
angetreten weil der michael und so
weiter meine freunde ändern unter
sekunde und im gymnasium und so weiter
klar ja viel gelesen und wir haben das
und das gelesen wir haben auch im westen
nichts neues und haben uns auch schon
mit jünger beschäftigt
selbstverständlich dass man hier
bedeutende leute über den krieg
berichtet haben sich wir wussten auch
dass der thomas mann in den ersten
weltkrieg einen aufruf das muss jetzt
sein und vaterländischen völkisch hat er
unser thomas mann
das würden wir nie denken aber so ist es
eben
und so ist es halt bei mir umgekehrt ich
habe gedacht ich werde das auch
einreißen und habe bis heute nichts
zustande gebracht aber ich möchte es
immer wieder thematisieren weil es
beginnt ja woanders
da uns die politik oft in unseren
ländern in einfach unbelegt lässt und
einfach notwendigkeiten feststellt ist
es wichtig dass wir mal wissen wie kommt
unter streit bei uns in der küche wie
kommt's woher kommt denn der was warum
regen wir uns auf warum im kindergarten
haben sich die buben und mädels auf den
kopf warum streiten die um nichts und
wieder nichts
kann man denn die sagen wir die kleine
situation in der küche wie sie jetzt
gerade beschreiben generalisieren auf
die weltpolitik glauben sie jeder
konflikt der konflikt in syrien genauso
wie der konflikt damals zum zweiten
weltkrieg geführt hat sind die gleichen
formen von küchen konflikt nein das auf
gar keinen fall das wäre ja zu glitschig
aber das bedeutet dass wir konflikte
langsam begreifen lernen und uns daran
gewöhnen das ist es ja darum ist er
jeder der einigermaßen klar über diese
dinge spricht nach kurzer zeit selber
nicht mehr im klaren weil er dann
denkens entschuldige seit jahrtausenden
gibt es dass du wirst es nicht ändern
und damit gibt man schon auf aber wir
sollten nicht aufgeben
die die die leute die und die wir
gewählt haben sollen immer wissen dass
es jemanden gibt der daran nicht
interessiert ist und sieht und dieser
zustand und ich nehme immer wieder
europa es hat ja keinen sinn dass sie
über ostasien reden oder so
ich habe auch gar keinen einfluss auf
irgendjemand der politiker also ich
kenne einige aber was soll ich mit denen
reden aber lernen wir dass gehen wir
hier sagen dass ich seine notwendigkeit
dass es so ist und entschuldige du
kleines job hatte mich da nicht ein na
ja da sind kein kleines job doch
immerhin eine gewisse vielleicht auch
vorbildfunktion in ihrer rolle als
berühmte persönlichkeit aus schauspieler
lassen sie mich noch einmal auf den
punkt zurück kommen die rolle des
theaters man hat ja schon eine zeit in
der man dachte das theater ist
eigentlich so etwas wie eine moralische
erziehungsanstalt ich denke auch an die
zeiten zurück meine eigenen studien
zeiten da haben wir selbstverständlich
in der kantine die neuesten inszenierung
am schauspielhaus diskutiert am neumarkt
theater
ich habe in tübingen auch studiert jeden
abend war man im zimmertheater und hat
sich die neuesten inszenierung wieder
angeguckt stücke mehrmals gesehen durch
diskutiert heute spricht man nicht mehr
so sehr über das theater würde ich
behaupten sondern über die neueste
netflix serie oder über den neuesten
pixar-film glauben sie das theater kann
heute noch so eine politische
sprengkraft haben und dabei fragen sie
mich warum ich die küche als erstes an
führe weil die jungen leute der sache
nach rennen weil sie netflix oder wie
das alles heißt das heißt das einzige
was wir zu tun haben ist doch das zu
thematisieren und sich zu fragen woher
kommt das eigentlich wer sie da
eigentlich jetzt wenn ich jetzt sage
ihnen vielleicht sagen wir mal bei kain
und abel an und bei dem das wir
vielleicht eine merkwürdigkeit sind weil
sie das gerade erwähnt haben
ich habe im jahre weiß ich jetzt nicht
mehr genau das könnte 68 gewesen sein am
züricher neumarkt ja den auftrag gehabt
zu spielen die lehne gerade romanzen er
hat es bei ein stück des russischen
autors ab und just in diese zeit hinein
fiel der prager frühling und hier ganz
zürich dass er nicht den zürcher gar
nicht zugetraut war in jedem winkel ein
tschechisches ist drei die drei experten
und 3g gewindelt und im sand corbis
jeder wurden diskussionen der halb
mittelfeld friedrich dürrenmatt und max
frisch und es war wirklich etwas los das
man dachte dass
muss auch das ist eigentlich jetzt gar
nicht sich sondern seine sind paris oder
in berlin und die die die jugend kocht
nein es war hier und es war ganz ganz
fantastisch und nicht weniger ist nur
sagen dann wurde dieses stück hat gesagt
in der kantorei da also im theater am
neumarkt weil es ein russisches stück
war
wir haben über ich habe ihn nie
herausgefunden wo wurden nach hause
geschickt und und das stück wurde nicht
gespielt das einzige mal in meinem leben
wo ich am theater ausbezahlt wurde was
einfach nicht gespielt wurde und der
grund war glaube ich weil es ein
russisches stück war der witz war der es
war von abos auf einem t sie denkt das
sehen sie dass es eigentlich ganz
merkwürdige entscheidungen gelegentlich
gibt weil wir nicht informiert sind das
heißt wir müssen uns in der küche im
wohnzimmer im schlafzimmer zu hause in
der schule in den kindergärten
informieren und scheide informiert
werden von leuten die all das zu geben
was sie über krieg oder ist das richtig
ist das falsch unter welchen umständen
und auch über das zusammenleben der
menschen persönlich äußern und ohne
irgendwie die hintertür und
sicherheitsnetze sondern so wie sie sind
und wenn sie etwas nicht wissen sollen
sie sagen aber auch keine ahnung die ich
bin ganz ich bin übrigens jetzt auch zu
ihnen ganz frisch gekommen
ich habe gar keine vorgefasste meinung
ich bin nur unglücklich darüber dass es
immer noch kraft und dass wir immer
wieder sehen dass leute unglaublich
sprechen und das roulette geht nach
hinten und nach vorne nach oben und rot
und grün und gehen von dort und berlin
und so weiter und es sterben
ununterbrochen menschen vor 20 jahren
wurden in europa noch mal in die genau
was in der nazizeit war in gräben wir
standen die menschen wurden
hineingeschossen etwas was wir
überwunden glaubten und jetzt merke ich
schon wieder ich habe vielleicht sogar
bei ihnen gar keine chance weil sie so
drüber sehnt über die ganze sache
jedenfalls blicken
[Gelächter]
also was mein blick auf sagt das gleich
mal dahin gestellt ich habe ja eine
interpretation zur möglichkeit doch
vielleicht ist ja auch völlig falsch
das kann sein ich hoffe ich glaube nur
die schwierigkeit ist doch dieses ganze
grauen von dem sie jetzt gesprochen
haben was sie wollen auch in den bildern
gesehen haben das macht uns alle
betroffen und ich versuche nur
herauszufinden was könnte die rolle ihre
spezifische rolle darin sein warum jetzt
dieses konzert zum thema krieg sie sagen
selber im programmheft das ja auch
gedruckt wird dass diese ist war die
soll da der soldat dabei strawinsky dass
der eigentlich ebenso gut ein soldat aus
syrien sein könnte kann es soll davon
über sein und zu allen seiten genau und
was können wir denn von diesen stücken
lernen wo denken sie
na ja da kann man wirklich vom theater
heraus etwas raus das ist das theater
mal weg das ist zufällig mein beruf und
sie machen einen anderen und werden das
selbe vielleicht auf ihrem banner haben
ja sie wollen nicht dass leute sich
gegenseitig umbringen grundsätzlich mal
nämlich anja und jeder kann natürlich
dass er arbeit nur was er zur verfügung
hat ich habe das theater zur verfügung
und vor allen dingen da bin ich ja schon
geschult ja es gibt ja kaum stücke wo es
nicht um leben und tod geht das ist dass
diese geschichte da zwischen diesen
beiden dingen findet ihr unser leben
statt ja und wenn sie wollen gibt es
auch noch philosophischen gedanken woher
kommen wir und wohin gehen wir
das kann schon sein obwohl es reicht mir
eigentlich das was ich erlebe selber zu
begreifen mit anderen zu besprechen und
mich dann für irgendetwas zu entscheiden
wissend dass ich mich vielleicht wird
nicht das ganz richtige für auch nicht
die richtige lösung aber ich bin auf
jeden fall dabei
das heißt wenn leute zum beispiel ihre
heimat leben und treffen auf jemand der
seine heimat liebt dann können sich
darüber unterhalten dass sie ihre heimat
lieben und dann können sie darüber reden
und sie müssen sich deshalb nicht die
köpfe einschlagen weil man ja weiß du
machst das deine ich mag dass meine aber
lasst uns darüber reden wir bleiben im
gespräch
machen sie es nicht so spezifisch
aus gerätes theater ich finde
theatermusik vor allen dingen musik
musik das unverschämt ist dass es
überhaupt gibt dann musik ist so
unverschämt dass wir uns einbilden
können wir denken jetzt das oder das und
ohne unabhängig vom komponisten was wir
wollen und können es benutzen für was
wir wollen
deine ausflug aber ich meine ich finde
dass kein ausflug ich finde das eine
sehr interessante auseinandersetzungen
einer und auseinandersetzung mit der
frage was soll eigentlich kunst und man
kann ja durchaus diese position
vertreten und ich glaube was ich lese
sie jetzt machen oder verstehen sie so
dass sie sagen hören sie auf damit das
theater zu moralisieren musik
beispielsweise ist in erster linie
eigentlich auch genuss es kann auch
sogar ein aufbegehren sein netz sagt er
zb wir brauchen die kunst um die welt
überhaupt auszuhalten und man sollte die
kunst gerade nicht moralisieren
das kann ja durchaus eine position sein
die ich auch sehr interessant finde
vielleicht ist es eher ehre ich habe
dagegen überhaupt nichts ich habe auch
nichts dagegen wenn leute zu
moralisieren das meer die können sie
jetzt jedes mal das machen aber ist open
moment aus seinem leben dort darf doch
jeder das machen was er will er muss es
nur ankündigen und sagen was man auch
ich bin sehr gegen dich und
weltanschaulich sowieso und ich werde
dich bekämpfen das ihn immerhin setzte
da kann man weiterreden
aber die dinge werden ja nicht weiter
geredet aus kinderhaus und dann hat der
recht der gewonnen hat das ist wie bei
fand also ich meine sie sehen ich werde
unglaublich nervös bei diesem thema weil
man das in kurzer zeit gar nicht sagen
kann sondern sie können nur ein beispiel
geben nur in der familie natürlich als
erstes was es bedeutet wie man ein
streit entschärfen kann
wie man ein streit aber nicht so
entschärft dass er wiederkommt sondern
wie man schaut dass man einen ausgleich
findet und wie das zu machen ist und das
beginnt im elternhaus das behielt mit
der auto rasch die sie haben ich kann
mich nur wiederholen
aus diesem grund machen wir das und
außerdem
die geschichte von dem einfachen
soldaten der wandert und wandert bis es
nicht mehr weiter kann und urlaub hatte
14 tage am esa und das mit der sohn von
heilige josef jetzt auch nicht mehr
darum wo ist das bild von meiner frau
wir haben ja noch ein foto vorher
gemacht oder ein bild malen lassen ist
auch nicht mehr da halo kommt einer zu
sorgen dass nichts zu fressen gibt nicht
eine geige fertig mit der soldat die mir
überhaupt nicht der die hat zwar nur
zehn fragwürdig gebe es nicht her und
die looks thema ab weil er sagt du wirst
alles haben in nur einen halben tag mit
mir nicht zu meiner mutter geht zu
meiner frau
da gehe ich hin nicht dagegen also die
verführung die verführen wieder
stattfindet und die damit der krieg mit
der verführung mithalten moment mit
allen beginnt alles beginnt mit
verführen wir verführen uns gegenseitig
sie laden mich ein verführen beweise
dass ich was vernünftige sage in ihrer
sendung und ich hoffe dass mir oder
werden lassen sich natürlich verfehlt
von ihrer schauspielkunst und komme ganz
vom konzept darf ich habe mir das hat
mit schauspielkunst überhaupt nichts zu
tun sondern das macht ihnen jeder an
einem normalen stammtisch weil mehr ist
es nicht was wir machen können wir
können uns unterhalten und mit einem
postulat beginnen sondern ich eben uhr
klar zu erkennen ich bin nur den zustand
der welt verzweifelt so jetzt können die
anderen sagt ja und ja also deshalb
meine damen und herren dienstagabend
tonhalle in zürich und wir versuchen und
glauben sie mir es ist nicht fahrt
darüber zu sprechen
und glauben sie mir es wird jeder
irgendetwas finden können wo einen
ansatz zumindestens hat und außerdem
eins ist auch klar ins theater ins musik
in die tonhalle
da gehen leute hin die irgendwie schon
eine ahnung haben die sich ja mit
geistigen dingen beschäftigen und die
sich sicherlich fragen weil es uns geht
man ja nicht in einem in einem tempel
der kultur
oder der musik sondern wir haben zu
bieten was haben wir zu bieten einen
eine straße die sehr lang sein wird und
vielleicht überhaupt kein ende hat
aber ich weigere mich sehr darüber
nur in einem verzweifelten worten form
zu reden dass durch oft selber gut genug
aber für mich aber es muss einen weg
geben zur besinnung zu kommen und ganz
einfach etwas finden
ach hätte dir doch eine kleine weile
gewartet so welcher von selbst gestorben
sagt er so gut ist und dann denkt man ja
viel wird er nicht mehr reden entwickelt
er ein unheimlich ein teppich über die
dinge des lebens das zusammenhänge des
kindseins des erwachsenseins der
schwierigkeit ein kind zu sein der
schwierigkeit als zu werden und so
weiter und es ist faszinierend und da
sitzen um ihn herum die die idee die
richter und die ganzen leute und
verurteilten ihn zum tode und macht
nichts ist als so können wir sagen gott
sei dank hat es ihn gegeben haben wir
immer wieder nachlesen ja und das ist ja
das was die griechen alles was wir lesen
können ist in dieser hat sicherlich
nichts mit kriegstreiberei zu tun
sondern hat zu tun wann werden wir
diesen fluch endlich abschütteln können
oder zu meinen mindestens argumente sind
es gibt argumente wo man sagt wenn die
uns dauernd hier bombardieren und alles
war dann müssen wir so weit sind wir
schon nur das tolle ist die handelnden
parteien sind schon so schlau dass sie
eigentlich da nehmer den andern
umbringen müssen ausradieren sondern wir
noch ein bisschen da bisschen wirtschaft
läuft die waffen werden
so haben wir jetzt eigentlich war vorhin
geliefert ja an beide auch wenn man
beide der natürlichen also ich kann das
nur in kürzeln sagen empört bin ich
gehört und es wird mir nicht merken dass
dienstag wird man nicht merken
er sprang ganz tolle leute von kafka bis
goethe und so weiter also durch jetzt
haben sie glaube ich hinreichend
deutlich gemacht dass sie nicht so gern
darauf angesprochen werden ihre rolle
als schauspieler oder die spezifische
verantwortung die vielleicht mit dem
schauspiel einhergehen können sie lassen
sie mich trotzdem noch ein thema war
weiter vertiefen und zwar indem wir uns
gemeinsam etwas anschauen
sie haben unter anderem ja den mephisto
gespielt in oscar preisgekrönten film
mephisto die verfilmung des romans
mephisto von klaus mann
istvan szabo und in dieser verfilmung
spielen sie hendrik höfken ein
schauspieler der eine großartige
karriere hinlegt aus karriere suchten
stück weit auch sich verführen lässt von
den nazis er wehrt sich zwar zuerst
gegen das regime aber immer mehr lässt
dass sich einlullen und profitiert von
diesem regime um eben diese karriere
machen zu können und am ende dieses
großartigen films betritt der
ministerpräsident gemeinsam in diesem
schauspieler das olympiastadion und der
wird durch das stadion gejagt verfolgt
von einem lichtkegel und diese szene
möchte ich mit ihnen anschauen
du wirst es nicht mich zu sein dass ich
das ist nicht wahr
[Musik]
was wollen sie von mir die ich bin doch
nur schauspieler
ich bin doch nur schauspieler herr
brandauer das ist sozusagen die
rechtfertigung zuletzt gilt dass ich bin
nur schauspieler überhaupt nicht aus
jedenfalls nicht für mich in deinem
beruf kann man sich nicht verstecken
darum habe ich ja so ungern wenn ich
immer als schauspieler angesprochen
werde das bin ich das bin ich ja
natürlich
das ist meine profession das ist meine
leidenschaft aber das wichtigste was man
sein kann ist ein mitgliedern der
gesellschaft in der man lebt und wenn es
geht und wenn sie mumm haben und wenn
sie auch was gedacht haben und sich
informiert haben dass ihre stimme
erheben deshalb müssen sie nicht
nationalratsabgeordneter werden nun auch
nicht bürgermeister aber es geht nichts
zu sagen ich interessiere mich nicht für
politik
das ist ein sehr politisches statement
der satz ich interessiere mich nicht für
politik aber ein saublödes das bedeutet
dass sie sich nämlich ausschließen aus
der gemeinschaft aber es ist wichtig
sich zu überlegen wird ein grünes bank
aufgestellt im krieger park und ein
rotes oder ein blaues usw
und wenn sie nicht wollen dass 1
aufgestellt wird dass sie nicht möchten
dann müssen sie es einfach sagen sie
können natürlich überstimmt werden
das heißt hinter einem beruf wie das ja
im dritten reich sehr oft geschehen ist
ich habe nur meine pflicht getan und so
weiter darum sagt dass sie auch dürften
das ist das eine ausrede
als dieser aber keine ausrede das ist
das aufregende das ponton von diesem
handy künftig werde es die
schlüsselfigur jetzt nicht bemühen weil
es handelt sich natürlich um eine
schlüsselfigur aber es muss der mann um
den es der da das vorbild war weil er
zufällig von klaus mann
der geliebte war über jahre nicht das
ist ja wie in einer ehe gewesen
das waren 1 1 ein homosexuelles pärchen
eine zeit lang und es ist auch alles in
ordnung turm hat man in diesem roman das
gefühl hier wird auch schmutzige wäsche
einer zweierbeziehung berichtet ich
finde es wohltuend dass der film von
istván szabó gezeigt hat dass ein mörder
system in deutschland und auch in teilen
von europa an der macht war
deshalb konnte ich mir erlauben alles zu
tun zu versuchen diesen herrn höfken
verständlich zu machen dass man sagen
kann ja das hat mir einen schauen sie
eines tages wird es vielleicht einen
moment geben
ich habe das beispiel mit unserem haus
und es soll also überrannt werden und
die leute werden soll umgebracht werden
gesagt jetzt vielleicht einen moment
geben wo ich sage ja jetzt haben wir
keine andere möglichkeit mehr aber wir
brauchen den moment mindestens die dort
müssen wir hinkommen aber wir haben
keine andere möglichkeit mehr aber
hinter einem beruf sich zu verstecken
ist ausgeschlossen
mich interessiert dieses moment der
frage kann man sich hinter etwas
verstecken sie haben ja in ihrer ganzen
karriere auffallend oft bösewichte
gespielt oder zwielichtige figuren und
man kann sich ja schon fragen gibt es
eigentlich das an sich böse in einem
menschen oder werden diese figuren immer
irgendwie korrumpiert durch ein system
in diesem fall ist es ja sozusagen die
naziherrschaft man kann sich nicht
dahinter verstecken dass man sagt das
war gar nicht ich das war nur meine
umgebung aber trotzdem stellt sich doch
die frage inwiefern sind menschen
eigentlich an sich böse und inwiefern
ist es immer das system das sie kopiert
also das ist dem allein kann natürlich
nicht sein dass er vollkommen klar dass
meine ich ja damit vielleicht können wir
es woanders abwälzen
das wird grundsätzlich böse sind also
ich glaube jeder der böse ist und
abgrundtief böse und schrecklich böse da
ist krank also ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass das von der natur
gewollt ist ja und wenn es von der
naturgewalt ist dann sehen wir ein
betriebsunfall der natur also hitler war
krank ich nehme an also ich meine
deshalb ist er trotzdem verantwortlich
für alles aber es kann doch nicht sein
dass jemand und vor allen dingen viel
wichtiger ist ja noch dass man diesem
einen noch qualen die chance gibt zu
regieren da ist ja nicht an die macht
gekommen durch einen umsturz wir wollen
aber diesen ich bin nicht jetzt 80 oder
90 jahre nach hitler gegen hitler das
ist mir zu einfach ja sondern ich bin
grundsätzlich für demokratische
verhältnisse in jedem land und überall
dort wo nur ein einzel davon ab
gestrichen werden soll sollen sich die
leute sehr sehr rühren und nicht einfach
mitgehen demokratie muss eigentlich
stündlich er sekündlich kontrolliert
werden vom volk
wir hatten eine große mitschuld wir alle
dass unser interesse manchmal auch nur
so weit geht bis zum 1
bis zu eigenen futterkrippe und das
ewig' kritisiert das zunächst einmal
überhaupt nicht ich möchte nur ins
bewusstsein rufen
durch meine arbeit wenn ich an professor
für politologie werde irgendwann würde
ist vergleicht anders versuchen ja
ständig vielleicht beim militär würde
ich sagen schafft man es ab aber wir
kriegen würde dass sie haben wir unsere
uniformen nicht mehr sprechen wir über
ihre arbeit ist seit 50 jahren auf der
bühne und im film eine lange zeit haben
unendlich viele verschiedene rollen
gespielt wie schlüpft man in eine rolle
weiß ich nicht genau
sie lesen einen text und haben
fertigkeiten das zu entschlüsseln und
stellen sich etwas vor und denken das
ziel wäre dass wird das vor leuten
aufhören oder ich vorlese wenn ich ein
leseabend mache oder mit anderen
freunden am theater aufführen und
schauen dass wir wären diese zeit solche
stoffe muss man sich natürlich aussuchen
was lernen ja dass wir eine freude dabei
haben und dann wenn wir auf gekommen
sind das hat uns interessiert müssen wir
hoffen dass die denen wir es zeigen auch
was damit anfangen können und das ist
die hohe und die bringen schrittes der
hat es und um mehr geht es überhaupt
nicht
aber wenn sie in eine rolle rein
schützen werden sie dann irgendwie
ähnlich wie diese figur also sind sie im
moment in dem sie julius cäsar spielen
haben sie den eindruck sie werden selber
ermordet werden also die
vorstellungskraft oder die ein
führungskraft in figuren den themen die
muss jeder für sich selber beantworten
wenn man kommt sehr früh drauf dass man
in der lage ist mit leuten mit zu leiten
besser als manche andere mit leuten mit
zu lachen besser als andere andere und
dass man es auch noch gerne manchmal
etwas deutlicher macht das ist also dass
es irgendwie zeigen können oder oder und
dass sie etwas haben was man ein zeige
oder ein spieltrieb nennen
und deshalb bin ich immer dafür dass wie
die wir in diesem ungefähren leben die
künstler nicht immer ernst genommen
werden sondern in der sache ernst aber
nicht immer in unseren postulaten weil
wir natürlich über unausgegorene dinge
da und sprechen es werden sehr viele
leute die keine schauspieler sind keine
künstler sind beraten über über ihre
dinge zu überlegen ob es schon
ausgegoren oder nicht ob unsere sind es
auf keinen fall
es ist ein moment in dem wir da sind und
etwas hinschmeißen und jetzt machen sie
was draus wir glauben es ist was da und
wenn das fahrrad ist zwei stunden
die ersten gedanken dann haben wir gar
keine chance sondern es muss
selbstverständlich und das macht der
zuschauer muss auch bereit sein sich
darauf ein und wir dass unsere aufgabe
unsere aufgabe ist und seine aufgabe ist
uns dabei zu beflügeln
es gibt abende an denen von unten nichts
kommt folglich kommt auch von oben
nichts außer dass wir genau dasselbe
machen wir am tag vorher nur es kommt
irgendwie zu nichts
es kann es sein dass ich mal schauen sie
halt ein bisschen auf mich er oder sie
uns sehe ich aus als würde ich
einschlafen noch nicht schlafen
überhaupt nicht ein ich würde gerne von
ihnen wissen können sie denn alles
spielen das wäre es ist doch vollkommen
wurscht ich weiß nicht weiß nicht mal ob
ich das was ich gespielt habe spielen
kann und sie sagen ich habe da und
bösewichte oder oder eingespielt hamlet
ist viel schlimmere mehrfacher mörder
richard dritte aber eher sollen
sensibler man dauernd denkt und von der
des gedankens blässe angekränkelt ein er
ist ein größerer mörder als der träger
der dritte gut ist in ordnung also so
missverständlich ist das ganze ja wir
werden ja nicht die die toten zählen
sondern darum geht es überhaupt nicht
ich habe wie ich draufgekommen bin ein
ziemliches einfühlungsvermögen und
manchmal gelingt mir etwas auch für mich
selber überraschend und erschreckend
dahin zu bekommen ja das ist nicht jeden
abend gleich aber das ziel ist so und
dazu brauche ich publikum das mich auch
beflügeln kann ohne publikum ist es ein
bisschen schwerer
obwohl ich auch bei büchern manchmal
wieso hast du jetzt da gelacht dabei
habe ich nur ein buch gelegt ist weißt
du lustig war oder es wurde schlichtweg
weil man es eigentlich nicht mehr
ertragen kann was da steht ja es gibt da
von kleist diesen diesen text über das
marionettentheater und da streicht er
heraus dass der anmutige tänze
eigentlich derjenige ist der vergiss das
spiel der will nicht überzeugen sondern
er vergisst sich eigentlich im spiel ist
das im schauspiel auch so wenn sie auf
der bühne stehen und ganz in einer rolle
drin sind vergessen sie dann dass sie
spielen es gibt schauspieler und musiker
und alle arten von berufsgattungen auch
in dem ausdrucksmöglichkeiten und es
gibt spezielle künstler künstler aus
welchen gründen auch immer vielleicht
ist persönlichkeit zu wenig und charisma
zu viel oder vielleicht ist genau das
richtige
keine ahnung eine wohl menschen mit sich
selber experimentiert haben bis zu einem
moment wo sie das gefühl haben jetzt und
jetzt beginnt das geheimnis und das
müssen sie jeden lassen das will ich gar
nicht besprechen also auch ein operateur
ein toller wird ihnen seine art zu
operieren und in verschiedenen punkten
nicht darlegen können wissen sie warum
weil es selber nicht weiß aber es ist
etwas und das haben sie selber auch
letztlich ist ein moment bei dem keine
ahnung erfahrung in ko alle damals diese
zwei minuten wurde aber beigetreten ist
und dann ist der träger nicht rein
geplatzt habe ich plötzlich wieder so
dagestanden
also ich muss ein bisschen ihr
theatervorstellung es ist alles
natürlich nur spiel aber jetzt muss ich
aber jetzt muss ich sie ein bisschen
festnahmen jetzt ziehen sich aus gewicht
ich habe nämlich zwei antworten gegeben
sie haben einerseits gesagt man muss
jeden künstler sein geheimnis lassen
sie verraten es mir nicht andererseits
haben sie gesagt wir wissen selber gar
nicht so recht ja über solid sagen das
ist das was wir schon wissen wie ich
weiß es auch nicht ich meine dass sie
sind dazu da nicht anzuschauen wenn sie
haben und und dann können sie ja
irgendwie eine meinung dazu bilden und
nicht der meinung zu mich zu mir als
person auch weil ich bin ja ich also
insofern sehen sie eigentlich immer mich
das ist auch ein ich bin einer der
wenigen der das gerne zugibt und mehr
noch nie eingebildet habe dass ich
wallenstein pin oder hamlet war oder mio
sondern es ist natürlich durch meine
brille und hoffentlich von shakespeare
oder von einem anderen großen und damit
meine ich nicht dass ich jetzt immer nur
klassiker meiner oder die alten griechen
oder sofort lässt sondern durchaus
menschen von heute die auch schreiben
auch zeitgenössisch über die sprech ich
lieber nicht weil ich niemanden falsch
hervorheben möchte aber sie haben
shakespeare wendt in shakespeare ist
ihnen ja sehr sehr nah sie haben einmal
auch gesagt shakespeare ist unerreicht
diese these stimmt auch für sie um das
sei unglaublich schwierig sich
shakespeare vom leib zu halten habe ich
gesagt ja was meinen sie damit
na ja also ich habe das gefühl dass das
klingt jetzt so als hätte er nur mit mir
zu tun
nein wenn ich sage er erkennt nicht so
gut dann meine ich erkennt uns menschen
so gut ja also nicht dass man wie jetzt
sagt ich habe da und kontakt bedienen
oder erklärte mich schon gekannt wie er
die stücke geschrieben hat nein es ist
das ist das interessante wo immer
shakespeare interessant ist auch dass er
zum beispiel in deutschland viel viel
öfter gespielt wird als in frankreich
das hat sicherlich auch mit der
übersetzung zu tun dass im französischen
das nachzuempfinden sprachlich
vielleicht schwieriger ist ja und als im
deutschen also der schlegel tieck hat da
ist eine riesengeschichte zustande
gebracht dass man fast glaubt xp ist ein
deutscher auf deutschsprachiger autor
aber nur durch die übersetzung leider
ist natürlich auch in den übersetzungen
verloren gegangen die die
gewalttätigkeit seiner sprache und
seiner situationen
das ist eine eine schrecklichkeit
gelegentlich ja eine schöne
schrecklichkeit aus der eine riesen
romanze entstehen kann
also ich habe noch nie ein stück so toll
empfunden als den sommernachtstraum wo
der krieg das umbringen das dach
was im einzelnen so groß wird und
umschlagen kann in sagen wir wieder gut
und nur mit damit diesen dingern
shakespeare nähern
das könne sie das können sie über von
meinem opa lernen vielleicht nicht so
toll wie von shakespeare
aber so wie man sich verhält dem leben
können sie von den menschen lernen
glauben sie alle sind auch unfreiwillig
sehr hilfreich geht's am flughafen oder
zwei leute haben spaß unter gewalt haben
wir letztlich weiß ich gar nicht und das
ist ein lächeln und man geht schon
wieder weitergeht da wo ist das
fernsehstudio eine fernseh straße
sowieso also ist man ist guter laune
also wunderbar jetzt haben die über die
verschiedenen rollen gesprochen über das
theaterspiel
natürlich drängt sich irgendwann die
frage auf hinter all diesen rollen gibt
es ja auch die echte person die echte
person klaus maria brandauer auch meine
echte person und es gibt ja heute diese
tendenz dazu dass man sagt man möchte
sich selber suchen sich selber
verwirklichen glauben sie es gibt so
etwas wie eine echtheit den menschen
naja natürlich also erst einmal sind wir
auf der welt um nicht zunächst ich
selbst zu sein sondern aufgrund von bubo
bubo bubo bubo das ist ein hause li bis
in fünf oder zehn jahren lernen müssen
das ist kein asyl sondern sein haus das
heißt die verbindung beginnt ja zuerst
kommen sie zinser tabu da im haus ist
und es wird sich um dieses kind dreht
sich alles und das ist der bescheid ist
und wir dort krieg das schon flächen usw
und dann geht es weiter also wir werden
natürlich schon irgendwie vorgebildet
und wie weit wir vorgebildet sind im
guten wie im schlechten
darum gibt es ja zumindest in den
christlichen religionen die erbsünde auf
die kann man sich jederzeit berufen
ich bin leider so und so geworden weil
ich habe ja endlich eine schöne
entschuldigung soll es nicht sein und
ist durchaus möglich dass es so ist denn
wenn wir alles andere erben kann
das ja auch sein dass wir gedanklich
grundsätze körperliche gehirn
gehirnwindungen mehr oder weniger ab
oder irgendetwas was davon abhängig ist
ob wir gut oder böse werden also ist
echtheit eine fiktion nein ich das
überhaupt keine fiktion aber so wie ich
glaube alles nur im augenblick war ist
so nämlich war hat dass man es in zehn
minuten nicht mehr so hinkriegt sondern
nur mehr interpretieren kann
das ist vielleicht auch das fantastische
faszinierende und auch vielleicht der
flug fluch unseres lebens sind wir
natürlich ständig auf der suche
und schön wäre natürlich wenn wir zu
erkenntnissen kommen dass wenn ich durch
zufall kommen sondern durch unseren
eigenen apparat aber wie soll man da hin
will durch den eigenen seite durch durch
durch das hier selber entscheiden was
sie haben wollen in unserem leben
entscheiden können sie schon ich bin oft
habe ich entschieden und ich bin ganz
sicher ich sag's nicht jedes war falsch
oder nur halb richtig also ich komme mit
diesen dingen nicht weiter zu befürchten
leid und das darf ich jetzt bereits in
meinem alter sagen sondern ich sage noch
einmal ich das ungefähre das nicht ganz
richtige das über das eck über die bande
ist etwas wo ich glaube ich selber
weiter komme was nicht bedeutet dass ich
nach reiflichen überlegungen
entscheidungen
wissen sie das ist ja eine grund
philosophische haltung linie die mir
sehr gefällt und auch imponiert dass man
zweifelt strafe gescheitert sich doch
wieder was zusammenzimmert und
weitermachen
mich interessiert aber trotzdem auch
diese vorstellung die beispielsweise
epiktet zum ausdruck gebracht hat diese
idee bedenke dass du nur ein
schauspieler bist in einem spiel dass
der spielleiter bestimmt also diese
vorstellung das gefühl gar nicht das
gefällt ihm gar nicht weil sie mit weil
sie nicht dass dieser noch der grössere
rückschritt jetzt sehen sie plötzlich
nur ein schauspieler von einem der sie
bestimmt dass das wäre auch noch um ihre
entschuldigung
nein das ist mir vollkommen wurscht das
würde die möglichkeit dass es eine
gott gibt ja völlig ad absurdum führen
das tun sollen
nein das top spiel leitet das ist nicht
der weiß es nur dass sie sich so und so
entscheiden
ja da ist viel höher als das was sie
gesagt haben sondern sondern dann dann
dann denn dann ist es einfach so dass
sie sich selbst aufgeben weil ein
anderer die fäden zieht dann werden sie
ja nie mensch das heißt sie wollen gott
treten und auch die freiheit ja wenn es
geht mitunter braucht unterwegs und
darunter worden zweifel ja das will ich
das will ich das schaue ich mir an
denn ich habe absolut immer wieder das
gefühl dass mich etwas beseelt das nicht
von dieser welt ist und natürlich
manchmal du kleiner scheißer
ja was soll ich machen aber da dort will
ich dann manchmal ist es zu ekstatisch
manchmal zu explosiv aber anders ist es
nicht denn kunst kommt aus dem feuer
wo soll sonst herkommen auszusuchen
vielleicht kurz kommt aus dem feuer aus
in diesem moment herr brandauer da
faszinieren sie mich auch extrem weil
ich glaube sie ist ja genau dieses diese
dieser zwiespalt aus dem sie vielleicht
auch ihre große kunst schaffen
einerseits die freiheit retten zu wollen
und gott treten zu wollen und in diesem
zwiespalt eine welt zusammen zu ziehen
in einem interview haben sie mal etwas
gesagt das ist mir nicht mehr aus dem
kopf gegangen und ich habe etwas
mitgebracht schauen sie ja sieg längst
nicht mehr so schön aber sie haben mir
gesagt dass sie glänzte kastanien
aufheben müssen weil sie die talismane
sinkt und das geht mir genauso
ich habe noch einen gesunden gestern
allerdings deswegen glänzt die nicht
mehr so schön
christoph gut genug hat mich dass auch
was mit diesem ringen zu tun man ist in
dieser eigentlich festgezurrten welt
alles fakten dinge von denen wir denken
die laufen einfach so und dann sieht man
die kastanien denkmal an kann kein
zufall sein ist ein talisman stecke ich
mir ein stück ja das was wir brauchen
die den talisman
da ich unglaublich fähig bin zum glauben
wäre hier natürlich auch unglaublich
fähig zum unglauben zum zweifel zu
entrichten dingen deren bin ich
besonders zugetan ich die
vielschichtigkeit die vielen schleier
ich brauche das aber ich brauch nicht
kastanien sondern ich brauche sie so
überreicht durch zufall durch bedacht
durch erinnerung das ist doch
unglaublich lieb von ihnen gefällt wird
so gut also und manchmal liegt einfach
um und dann glänzt sie gar nicht und
wissen sie was ich nehme sie trotz
drehen sich die trotzdem es gibt noch
was anderes was mich interessiert an den
kastanien habe ich auch mitgenommen
schauen sie mal die schale ist natürlich
sache liegt aber nicht gar nicht die
stacheln die mich faszinieren was nicht
immer interessiert an den kastanien ist
wie die zerbrechen
die haben ja so sollbruchstellen und
allein schon der begriff der
sollbruchstelle das etwas da bricht
losbrechen soll dieser begriff der lässt
sich schon seit jahren nicht mehr los
dass die sollbruchstelle ich frage mich
die ganze zeit haben die menschen
sollbruchstellen gibt es solche risse in
uns drin wo klar ist da müssen ja auch
einfach mal brechen dass die frage ist
ob der bruch dann etwas ist was sie
grundsätzlich total verändert oder was
sie weiterbringt
wissen sie ich habe mal eine vase eine
chinesische vase
ich habe bestimmt ja das gehört nicht
uns vorbei bei einem besuch
umgeschmissen und dann habe ich weil wir
auch schon ein bisschen was getrunken
gehabt so macht sie halt wieder zusammen
ja das wurde auch gemacht und das war
die phase ist mein vermeiden fühlt viele
jahre her
noch toller geworden weil es ist
dieselbe weise aber man sieht
die bruchstellen es ist auch das kit bar
wieder vereinbar
die bruch die sollbruchstellen ist ein
auftrag aber es wieder zusammenzubringen
ist auch ein auftrag und vielleicht die
lösung vielleicht die lösung ja da muss
ich jetzt länger darüber nachdenken
vielleicht schreibe ich ihnen wenn ich
länger darüber nachgedacht ich habe
bitte lassen sie mich lassen sie mich
zum schluss nochmals zu shakespeare
zurückkommen dann ist es immer so
beschäftigt hat diese vorstellung bei
shakespeare diese viel viel besser
kennen als ich dass die ganze welt eine
bühne ist auf der wir auftreten und
irgendwann wieder abtreten das hat ja
auch nicht nur dieses moment dass wir
wissen wir kommen wir spielen unser
leben und wir gehen wieder
sonst hat doch auch dieses moment das
man denkt es kommen alle figuren immer
wieder vielleicht entwickeln die uns gar
nicht so sehr und das geht vielleicht
zurück an den anfang unseres gesprächs
eben die haben wir diesen krieg in uns
es kommt das immer wieder gleiche ist
das ein stück weit auch das was bei
shakespeare anklingt die welt die ist
einfach so wie sie ist sie entwickelt
sich nicht wirklich wir haben die immer
gleichen rollen die wir wieder neu
spielen diesem moment dass wir das
bewusst wird immer mehr vor dem fürchte
ich mich schon seit über 60 jahren sei
das gymnasium verlassen habe ich fürchte
mich davor dass es so sein wird das ich
denke selbst in einer fantastischen form
der ewigen wiedergeburten und wieder
geboten und so weiter dass sich das
unser auftrag gar nicht ist ist
irgendetwas zu verändern
das kann ja sein nur dagegen halte ich
dass es in allen bereichen unglaubliche
fortschritte gibt technik medizin und so
weiter im aufschreiben im zusammenleben
im denken in singen im miteinander aus
im menschlichen bereich gibt
glauben was anderes nichts
es gibt nichts unter uns zu zweit nicht
und miteinander nicht was nicht schon
gemacht wir haben gelacht oder auch bei
den autoren sie sollen bitte um gottes
willen nichts einbilden manchmal habe
ich das glück habe ich schon gelesen nur
weil die erstausgabe ja oder manchmal
wenn es mir nicht gefällt mach ich mir
die nächsten seiten allein und schreibe
mehr allein weiter das buch ja oder
manchmal habe ich nicht verstanden wenn
ich es ja nicht bin blätter ich zurück
aber auch alles da ich habe immer wieder
das gefühl wir nicht weil ich so viel
gelesen so gescheit bin dass ich kenne
ich weiß ich woher und das ist das
aufregende es wird mich hoffentlich
nicht erwischen
dass ich sage ich habe die ganze zeit
was er schon immer gemacht wurde ich
möchte dass immer wieder haben den riss
der möchte ich immer wieder haben weil
sonst
ich weiß zwar nicht wie es dann ist kann
er vielleicht schiebt sich mir dass er
ein was ich in einem film vor einiger
zeit dargestellt habe dass man mir dann
plötzlich sagt ich bin dement und
anklagen und alles möglich vielleicht
sogar eigentlich werden wird man in
jahrzehnten sein da ist eigentlich
klinisch tot weil jemand der sich nicht
mehr erinnert der lebt ja gar nicht mehr
davon überzeugt bin jemand der sich
nicht mehr erinnern kann hat kein leben
mehr sprechen und in die ausländer
einmal klein auheim ich hatte nie das
gefühl dass ich auch skilled wischt
werde im gegenteil ich empfand auch
während dieser drei arbeitnehmer
wunderbare momente und leider hatten die
nada will mich dorthin wo ich ihn gern
hin gehabt hätte also in den nicht
glaube ich nicht gefordert oder so aber
so was möchte ich noch mal versuchen in
das stadium danach also wo man sich
nicht umbringen lässt oder und bringt
sondern was ist da ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen
der fischer endet ja ja ich habe den
walter jens in einem film gesehen weil
sie herum gefahren wurde und ich kannte
den ganz gut er zwei mal etwas
geschrieben was ich dann als konzert mit
musik aufgeführt habe und ein ganz
unglaublicher mann der mich leider zu
wenig begegnen
aber ich hatte immer das gefühl kommen
da und dafür bin ich der ist so lange da
ist da und hat dieselben gedanken wie
wir das nehme ich als schluss herr
brandauer
ich danke ihnen sehr für dieses gespräch
war sehr sehr gern hier bleiben
das freut mich dankeschön falls sie von
meinem heutigen gast noch nicht genug
haben das konzert des zürcher
kammerorchesters mit klaus maria
brandauer findet diesen dienstag um
19.30 in der tonhalle zürich statt und
es gibt noch karten
nächste woche ist bangkok sprach er zu
gast
der britisch indische schriftsteller
hält in seinen büchern dem westen den
spiegel vor und was sich darin spiegelt
ist keineswegs nur schön sondern zeigt
nach wie vor die hässliche fratze des
kolonialismus
ich diskutiere mit kann pankatz mishra
welche lektionen der westen noch zu
lernen hat jetzt gleich geht's hier
weiter mit einem film über den schweizer
künstler alberto giacometti
ich wünsche ihnen viel vergnügen damit
und einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]